(audience applauds)
("9 to 5" by Dolly Parton)
♪ Tumble out of bed and I
stumble to the kitchen ♪
♪ Pour myself a cup of ambition ♪
♪ Yawn and stretch and
try to come to life ♪
♪ Jump in the shower and
the blood starts pumpin' ♪
♪ Out on the street
the traffic's jumpin' ♪
♪ With folks like me on
the job from nine to five ♪
♪ Nine to five ♪
- [Kelly] Give it up for Dolly Parton!
♪ Working nine to five ♪
♪ What a way to make a livin' ♪
♪ Barely gettin' by ♪
♪ It's all takin' and no givin' ♪
♪ They just use your mind ♪
♪ And they never give you credit ♪
♪ It's enough to drive
you crazy if you let it ♪
♪ Nine to five ♪
♪ For service and devotion ♪
♪ You would think that I would
deserve a fat promotion ♪
♪ Want to move ahead ♪
♪ But the boss won't seem to let me ♪
♪ I swear sometimes that
man is out to get me ♪
(Dolly and Kelly hum)
♪ They let you dream just
to watch 'em shatter ♪
♪ You're just a step on
the boss man's ladder ♪
♪ But you got dreams
he'll never take away ♪
- [Dolly] Take it.
♪ You're in the same boat
with a lot of your friends ♪
♪ Waitin' for the day
your ship'll come in ♪
♪ Tide's gonna turn and it's all gonna ♪
♪ Roll your away ♪
♪ I just know it ♪
♪ Workin' nine to five ♪
♪ What a way to make livin' ♪
♪ Barely gettin' by ♪
♪ It's all takin' and no givin' ♪
♪ They just use your mind ♪
♪ And they never give you credit ♪
♪ It's enough to drive
you crazy if you let it ♪
♪ Nine to five ♪
♪ They got you where they want you ♪
♪ There's a better life ♪
♪ And you dream about it don't you ♪
♪ It's a rich man's game ♪
♪ I don't care what they call it ♪
♪ And you spend your life
putting money in his wallet ♪
♪ Nine to five ♪
Yeah!
(audience cheers and applauds)
- I'm just doing this.
- Hello, hello, hello.
Thank you to the band.
- Oh my god.